bonsoir Le Journal de la rédaction
nouvelle édition en ce mercredi 12
novembre nous allons faire le tour de
l'actualité locale il est 18h si vous
nous suivez en direct et ce soir le
dénouement pour la mission Rosetta le
robot fila est déployé sur la comète
churi pour livrer les secrets du système
solaire l'observatoire de Versailles 50
ans en nuveline partie prenante de cette
aventure retransmet actuellement les
images de l'événement historique avec
les commentaires des chercheurs la
région Île-de-France met en avant son
dispositif rebond qui permet de venir en
aide aux entreprises en difficulté le
président jean-pauluchon en déplacement
à Houdan pour rencontrer les effectifs
du dernier abattoir francilien qui a
bénéficié de cette aide et puis les
commémorations du 11 novembre qui ont
attiré les foules notamment à Montini le
bretonux un hommage appuyé par les
jeunes les élus et les représentants des
villes jumelles depuis 8h 10 ce mercredi
matin après 6 milliards de kilomètres
parcourus en 10 ans de voyage la sonde
spatiale Rosetta a lancé le robot filae
en direction de la comète Chuy
l'événement est à la hauteur des
premiers pas de l'homme sur la Lune
puisque nous pourrions en apprendre plus
sur l'origine de notre système solaire
l'OVSQ l'observatoire de Versailles 50
ans nveline propose en ce moment même de
vivre l'événement au côté de ses
chercheurs impliqués d'ailleurs dans
cette mission à 18h en ce mercredi
quelques photos ont commencé à arriver
c'est d'ors et déjà un fil c'est bien
posé on écoute le directeur du
laboratoire atmosphère milieu
observation spatiale de l'OVSQ
l'observatoire de de sa Quentin des
propos recueillis en fin de journée il
nous explique le travail qu'il reste
maintenant à accomplir on est très loin
donc l'information vient au
comptegoutte donc on est va falloir
attendre et donc là par rapport à
l'instant présent les choses arrivent
petit à petit donc on a beaucoup
d'informations sur où se place filae
donc on peut on peut on peut avec les
mesures savoir où il est mais on voit
pas ce qui se passe donc il y a une
incertitude toujours il y a deux enjeux
il y a il y a le rôle de la comète objet
primitif du système solaire et donc
revenir dans le passé finalement comment
était le le le le le de quoi était
composé le le système solaire primitif
et l'autre enjeu c'est c'est c'est
effectivement les comètes quel rôle ont
pu-t-ils jouer
puisqueeffectivement ce genre de corps
on en reçoit alors Dieu merci grâce à
not atmosphère plus trop mais mais dans
une TER primitive on a reçu beaucoup de
ces objets donc quel a été l'impact de
ces objets dans la composition
atmosphérique que l'on a aujourd'hui
c'est pasà c'est tout l'enjeux et et du
coup quels sont les les espèces qui ont
pu participer peut-être à à à la vie sur
Terre donc là il y a des enjeux très
très
important et nous y reviendrons bien
évidemment plus en détail dans notre
prochaine édition demain jeudi puisque
nous sommes à l'université de versaill
Saint-Quentin en iely nous allons rester
encore quelques instants avec un autre
genre d'événement lundi à l'université
euh 50 ans en Yveline donc l'association
étudiante ikcar a organisé une
conférence à propos du conflit
israélo-palestinien intitulé avoir 20
ans en Palestine conférence lors de
laquelle deux étudiants palestiniens
sont venus pour partager leurs
expériences sur ce conflit ils espèrent
ainsi informer les étudiants sur l'état
actuel de la situation les sensibiliser
sur les conditions de vie de leurs
homologues Palestiniens dans ce contexte
it's
about on va témoigner de notre
expérience montrer aux étudiants ce que
nous vivons en Palestine
on veut les interpeller partager avec
eux pour qu'ils nous comprennent mieux
et nous aide à faire face à
l'occupation nous sommes non violents
nous résistons de manière
pacifique mais nous faisons face à une
occupation armée et à des soldats en
armes nous voulons que tout le monde en
France nous supporte et soit solidaire
avec les
Palestiniens c'est de de soutenir de
soutenir les personnes d'abord qui
vivent là-bas et de demander
la paix en fait qu'il y ait un processus
de paix qui soit amorcé et qui aille au
bout dans l'optique de la reconnaissance
de l'État palestinien économie après un
dépôt de bilan à la fin des années 80
les abattoirs guaran à Oudan semblent
aujourd'hui sur le bon chemin le
résultat en partie du soutien de la
Région Île-de-France avec un prêt de
plus de 250000 € pour réaliser les
investissements nécessaire à sa
compétitivité le président socialiste de
la région Jean-Paul Huchon s'est rendu
sur place mercredi après-midi le
reportage de yolen Torz et de Patrick
Jacques de
dixmud c'est une visite pas comme les
autres Jean-Paul huchan président du
Conseil régional d'Île-de-France
découvre ici à Oudan le dernier abattoir
porsin de la région la région qui
soutient financièrement cet abattoir par
un dispositif appelé rebond prévention
mise en place depuis plus de 8 mois il a
accordé un prêt de 250000 € à cette
entreprise pour plusieurs raisons ici on
voit bien que il mise sur la proximité
de la production de la viande et sa
diffusion dans les commerces locaux ou
jusqu'à Paris évidemment c'est un c'est
un atout dans la concurrence et c'est le
dernier endroit où on abat et o on
découpe et on prépare les ports en Île
de France ce dispositif propre aux
entreprises en difficulté guaran en a
fait partie notamment en 2004 lors de la
crise de la vachefolle qui interdit les
farines animal
la société descend alors à 74 salariés
et a même été contrainte à un moment
donné de déposer le bilan aujourd'hui
grâce au dispositif les effectifs sont
remontés à 87 employés et de nouveaux
investissements sont même envisagés nous
avons développé une gamme avec des
éleveurs d'île-defance une gamme de porc
francyin élevé à la graine de lin que
nous proposons à la grande distribution
et qui nous demande d'emballer ce port
pour des plus petite de distribution
donc on va investir dans une machine à
mettre sous
emballage modifié l'avantage du prêt
c'est aussi que le remboursement est
différé de 2 ans aucune garantie n'est
demandée sur les actifs de l'entreprise
ni aucune caution personnelle du
dirigeant après moins d'un an d'activité
le dispositif rebond a permis de
sécuriser 1700 emplois dans différentes
société la maladie d'Alzheimer nous
parlons santé une maladie
neurodégénérative incurable qui touche
directement ou indirectement près de 3
millions de Français aucun traitement
uniquement des soins palliatifs pour
l'entourage également un besoin d'aide
de soutien ainsi une halte RPI va avoir
le jour au clés sous-bois l'ouverture
est prévue dans quelques jours bonsoir
Marie thérèe Ros bienvenue en plateau
vous êtes la présidente du réseau Carmat
le Réseau Santé gérontologique de
professionnels libéraux tout d'abord il
y a un peu de retard l'ouverture était
prévue cette semaine ça a été décalé au
au 24 novembre pourquoi ce ce léger
retard B parce que nous avons fait une
réunion avec les bénévoles puisque cette
structure va fonctionner principalement
avec des bénévoles et il est apparu
qu'il y avait des petites choses encore
qu'il fallait compléter elle voulait des
tableaux enfin donc on a retardé un
petit peu pour le faire vraiment
tranquillement et que tous ceux qui vont
encadrer se sent à l'aise et ce sera
donc le 24 novembre pour pour
l'ouverture officivembre on a repoussé
d'une semaine en quoi consiste alors une
al rpie plus précisément ce sera un club
ri convivialité que vous allez mettre en
ou un club oui oui c'est ce sont pas des
enfants c'est un club c'est-à-dire que
il y a beaucoup de choses qui existent
au niveau Alzheimer il y a des alcueils
de jour des hôpitaux de jour mais il y
avait rien qui permettait aux proches
s'ils avaient besoin de 2h ou 3h de
façon imprévue ou simplement parce que
ils ont vie un petit peu de respirer il
y avait rien donc on a eu l'idée de
créer cette cette structure on a eu un
financement de la Fondation de France
donc là c'est quelque chose où les les
proches pourront à n'importe quel moment
ils pourront téléphoner bien sûr la
veille ou la avant veille pour demander
si leur proche peut venir passer 1h 2h
3h ou 4h puisque c'est 13h30 à 17h30
dans ce club alors c'est à la fois un
accueil pour les personnes atteintes de
la maladie d'Alzheimer mais aussi pour
leurs proches on veut que ce soit
quelque chose de très convivial
c'est-à-dire ils pourront venir prendre
un café il y a des dehors il y a des
appareils pour faire un peu de gym qui
peuvent très bien faire avec leurs
proches ou tout seul il y aura également
une salle de peinture enfin qui est
installé c'est très gay c'est très
convivial et ça pourrait être vraiment
un moment où c'est pour la personne qui
sera stimulé qui sera sécurisé qu' aura
des choses à faire et aussi pour le
proche qui va pouvoir souffler un peu
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure vous
m'avez repris au tout début c'est
important ce ne sont pas des enfants
vous insistz vraiment là-dessus parce
que la perception quelquefois des
personnes qui sont atteintes par cette
maladie là c'est un rejet en tout cas
une difficulté pour les les les
entourants pour les personnes qui sont
là au quotidien il faut pas infantiliser
ce ne sont pas des les enfants voà non
ce sont des adultes qu' ont eu un passé
qu' ont une vie qui ont un certain âge
et on doit les traiter comme t voyez par
exemple c'est pour ça qu'on a fait une
salle peinture mais c'est avec des
chevalets des toiles de la peinture et
ce sont des personnes qui sont inscrite
pour encadrer ce cet atelier qui sont
des gens qui font de la peinture donc si
vous voulez par exemple si quelqu'un
rapporte chez lui après une journée
passée quelque part un
coloriage c'est les enfants qui
rapportent des coloriages si vous
rapportez une toile en abstrait c'est
toujours joli c'est jamais quelque chose
d'infantilisant donc si vous voulez ça
c'est extrêmement important c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a voulu garder tout
est fait pour les personnes qui ont un
certain âge et qui onoque d'humanité
quelque fois justement la prise en
compte des personnes atteintes par la
maladie d'Alzheimer ça manque d'humanité
on manque d'humanité quelque fois pas
d'humanité mais on a trop tendance je
crois et c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
faut être honnête mais à à devenir
d'ailleurs il y a ces deux termes qui
existent dès qu'on a mis dit d'Alzheimer
on parle des dents h alors nous on dit
bien et je crois que ça c'est important
on dit vous restez quand même avant tout
ou le mari ou la femme ou les enfants et
les parents et ça je crois que c'est
important bien sûr c'est pas facile hein
faut être clair mais ce sont des adultes
et on doit les considérer comme tels et
ce sont des personnes qui on a vécu et
on doit en tenir compte vous avez
commencé à nous expliquer comment
fonctionnait cette structure il suffira
en quelque sorte de téléphoner pour
s'inscrire voilà la personne puisse
venir mais combien de place est-ce que
ça sera suffisant pour répondre à à la
demande bah ça on sait pas du tout parce
que ça pas encore commencer on avait
fait une étude de enfin pour voir si ça
répondait vraiment au besoins et là on a
vu effectivement ça avait été une
unanimité assez importante maintenant il
est vrai que l'objectif aussi c'est
peut-être de développer ça dans d'autres
secteurs ce sera ouvert uniquement pour
les personnes qui habitent sur les
clés il y aura aucune condition ce sera
ouvert à tout le monde ouvert en semaine
on le rappelle sur alors toute la
semaine tous les après-midis de 13h30 à
17h30 sur simple coup de fil alors s'il
y a de la place on dit oui s'il y a pas
de place on dit bah faut téléphoner pour
demain ou aprèsdemain il y aura un coout
forcément alors il y aura un coût de 4 €
de l'heure on veut que ce soit
accessible pour tout le monde alors on
me dit toujours faut pas dire parce
qu'autrement tout le monde va dire qu'il
peut pas mais il est clair qu'il ne faut
pas que l'argent soit un obstacle à ce
que toutes les familles puissent et tous
les proches bénéficier de ce service et
ce sont des bénévoles ensuite qui vont
intervenir alors c'est une équipe de
bénévoles entièrement bénévole on a 26
personnes il y a même des on essaie de
faire que ce soit un peu
intergénérationnel mais ça ça ne jouera
que sur le mercredi mais on a déjà des
jeunes qui sont intéressés enfin qui
sont passionnés par cette aventure et
qui donneront un peu de leur temps le le
mercredi ou quelquefois bon en semaine
pour les plus grands alors pas forcément
bien sûr pour encadrer comme un adulte
mais mais il y en a qui me disent bah
moi je joue de la guitare je viendrais
faire un petit un petit Chose de guitare
un autre qui dit bah on dansera enfin
voyez il faut que ça reste très vivant
he que ce soit de la vie on n pas d'idée
préconçu toutes les bonnes volontés
seront là et tous ceux pas hésiter à
rentrer en contact avec vous avec le le
réseau Carmat donc sur ce club repi
convivialité qui va ouvrir aux clés
sousbois on disait ce sera le le 24 avec
votre structure et d'autres structures
qui se mettent en place des activités
qui se mettent en place autour de la
maladie d'Alzheimer est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui il y a une
vraie prise de consci
des besoins et pour les malades et pour
leur entourage est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
apporte une réponse satisfaisante oui il
y a une grande prise de conscience ce
qu'il y a si vous voulez c'est que c'est
encore trop dispersé c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a des initiatives un peu partout même
le gouvernement lance des choses mais
pour l'instant c'est un peu difficile de
s'y retrouver si on est un proche au
démarrage justement vous parliez du
gouvernement un plan devait être
présenté un plan pour les prochaines
années la présentation du plan par le
gouvernement était prévu à la fin du
mois d'octobre il a été repousé c'est
tout déb novembre et puis finalement il
n'y a pas de nouvelle date qui a été
communiquée autour de la présentation du
plan Alzheimer du gouvernement faut y
voir un sigau
d'inquiétude vous vous êtes inquiète
comment vous le percevez bah si vous
voulez je vais être très honnête on
nattend pas parce que si on attend on
fait rien donc on fait si ça marche et
qu' est une bonne nouvelle ce sera du
plus vous n'attendez rien mais mais
néanmoins qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait en
plus qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez voir
impulsé par le gouvernement une
structure pour coordonner aussi
peut-être toutes les bonnes volonté déjà
voilà peut-être alors les réseaux de
santé sont fait pour ça aussi mais si
vous voulez ils ont créé un peu dans le
désordre il y a eu les Mayas les réseaux
de santé qui doivent aussi prendre en
charge le patient Alzheimer il y a au
niveau des SIAD les essa des équipes qui
prennent aussi en charge et je pense
qu'il faudra arriver à ce qu'on
travaille tous ensemble il y a Fran
Alzheimer avec qui nous on travaille il
y a lion Alzheimer le lionce club
alzemor voyez il y a plein de bonnes
volonté mais pour l'instant c'est un peu
dispersé il faudrait vraiment qu'on on
arrive à tous s'entendre à dialoguer
ensemble et à créer une véritable prise
en charge qui soit bien visible pour
tout le monde et le problème c'est que
bon dans nos régions on est un peu
favorisé quoi il faudrait que ça puisse
aussi s'étendre sur l'ensemble de on a
souvent des coup de fil de de personnes
qui sont en province où il y a rien du
tout HM mais sur un tel plan comme celui
qui devait être présenté et qui on
l'espère sera présenté dans les dans les
prochaines semaines vous êtes consulté
sur ce genre de choses-là en tant que
réseau justement que dans ces choses-là
la base n'est jamais consultée on
consultera pas ceux qui sont au
quotidien est-ce que vous intervenez au
quotidien justement voilà donc on
imaginer que vous soyez sollicité pour
amener vos réflexions on fait beaucoup
de on parle beaucoup des aidents mais
demandz combien d'aidents auront été
sollicités pour dire leur avis leurs
difficultés combien de professionnels
qui sont confrontés tous les jours à ce
genre de problème seront non on a eu
aucune demande nulle part or nous dans
nos prises en charge on a actuellement
so 61% 61 % des personnes qu' prend en
charge qu' des troubles cognitifs pas
tous la maladie d'Alzheimer mais des
troubles cognitifs ce qui est quand même
énorme c'est un tableau assez noir que
vous dressez parce que ça veut dire que
s'il n'y a pas de bonne volonté rien ne
se fera finalement je pense que bah vous
savez c'est comme tout le temps si ça
part pas de la base ce qui tombe de
làhaut n'est pas forcément ce qui est
utile sur le terrain et si ça part du
terrain il faut un certain temps pour se
faire entendre merci d'être venu ce soir
pour témoigner pour nous parler aussi de
ce club épiconvivialité qui va ouvrir au
clés sous-bois merci encore à vous nous
nous y reviendrons bien sûr dans une
prochaine édition l'ouverture est prévue
le 24 novembre hier la France célébré
les commémorations du 11 novembre date
de l'armistice de la Grande Guerre à
montiné le Bretonneux devant le Monument
au Morts des centaines de riverins sont
venu assister à la cérémonie les élus
locaux les représentants des villes
jumelles étaient présents avec
l'orchestre du 1078 mais aussi des
élèves 250 élèves de six écoles de la
commune qui ont participé très
activement à l'événement le reportage de
de William
l à Montini le breteneux la
commémoration de l'Armistice rassemble
aujourd'hui peu importe la génération
une seule chose compte le
souvenir mlier Albert mort pour la
patrie tourau Jean-Marie mort pour la
patrie cette année 250 élèves participai
à la cérémonie pour rendre hommage des
lectures de textes Sarah elle a lu la
lettre écrite par un enfant pour son
père sur le front nous nous inquiétons
beaucoup car depuis le 17 avril nous
n'avons pas de nouell et malgré leur
jeune âge le devoir de mémoire semble
bien
assimilé c'est très important parce que
il y en a qui ont fait la guerre ils se
sont ils se sont battus pour Montini la
France et on a besoin de leur rendre
hommage pour tout ce qu'ils ont fait la
guerre 141 c'est c'est un symbole c'est
c'est important pour nous mourir pour la
France c'est quelque chose et c'est pas
c'est pas comme jouer ou se rappeler de
ses morts mais aussi et surtout prévenir
les générations futures ce qui s'est
passé auparavant nous permet de mieux
affronter l'avenir avec peut-être en
modifiant certaines erreurs la seule
chose que j'avais retenu lorsque j'étais
petit c'est que le vin était gelé durant
la la guerre et qui découpait le vin à
la hache et quand on est enfant ça ça
end après les dépôts de gerbes devant le
Monument au Morts les enfants
entonnent la
Marseillaise ému les représentants des
villes jumelles de Grande-Bretagne et
d'Allemagne ont assister à la cérémonie
c'était très très impressionnant parce
que nous on connait pas ça on fait pas
on ne fait pas de T cérémonie chez nous
les cérémonies pour
les pour les MS qui sont tombés dans les
guerres ça se déroule pres presque dans
la clandestinité c'est impressionnant
pour nous et très très émouvant surtout
quand on a vu les petits là qui
chantaiit la
Marseillaise enfin direction l'ancienne
mairie pour se recueillir une dernière
fois devant la plaque des instituteurs
ici on chantera une fois encore l'hymne
national cette fois à la demande des
enfants
March
imp
Bron une belle Marseillaise à Montini le
bretonux c'est hier matin également qui
a été dévoilé attrape la statue de Jean
jores toujours à l'occasion de cette
commémoration de la fin de la Grande
Guerre et de l'anniversaire de la mort
de ce parlementaire pacifiste la
sculpture de bronze a été érigée face à
l'Hôtel de Ville elle est signée
Jean-Charles ménardis l'inauguration
s'est faite en présence des habitants et
des élus c'est un travail qui est
réalisé à partir de modèle donc c'est
toujours la la figure humaine qui est le
centre de mon travail il est dans un
mouvement de marche léger mouvement donc
il regarde légèrement sur la droite
parce que le centre de la circulation va
changer donc quand on va arriver à traap
on va voir la Jean jorè en premier lieu
j'ai essayé de le représenter dans une
attitude naturelle parce qu'il je
voulais qu'il soit proche des passants
proche donc des habitants de trappe
c'est le ce anniversaire malheureusement
de sa mort je tiens à le dire
l'importance pour nous de de cet homme
de paix qui est cher à notre cœur et
c'est vraiment une action qu'on veut
mettre au cœur de notre ville la paix le
partage de vivre ensemble et nous
reviendrons une nouvelle fois dans nos
prochaines éditions sur cette grande
guerre sur les commémorations mais
également sur ce que cela représente et
sur les événements qui sont organisés
dans le département avec des
responsables des Archives
départementales des ivelines sur ce
plateau ce sera demain des 18h en direct
construire et rénoveré dans le respect
de l'environnement c'était le thème du
forum ecabitat le weekend dernier à
jouant Josas une thématique porteuse
d'autant que ces travaux sont souvent
synonymes de sérieuses économies sur les
factures des ménages retour sur ce
rendez-vous avec Mélanie poket et
William
l laine de verre polyester Liège des
produits naturels comme synthétiqu au
choix du client mais avant tout il faut
prêter attention à l'état actuel de la
maison il faut tout d'abord commencer
par regarder quel est le l'état de la
maison s'il y a des travaux importants à
prévoir dans la maison ou si c'est
simplement une redécoration de la maison
que les clients soitent faire si ce sont
des travaux importants il faut peut-être
faire appel à un termicien pour évaluer
effectivement le niveau de déperdition
de la maison et pouvoir je dirais
reprendre les éléments les plus
importants les plus déperditifs de de la
construction actuelle faire des devis
auprès de thermiciens pour établir les
capacités thermiques d'une maison et
déterminer les principales sources de
perte de chaleur les fenêtres sont
souvent les zones où la chaleur
s'échappe le plus fréquemment notamment
le simple vitrage
mais il n'y a pas seulement les fenêtres
la chaudière ou la toiture peuvent être
des pertes de chaleur et d'énergie les
isolants naturels sont plus onéreux car
peu développé donc les travaux ont un
coût mais l'État et les collectivités
ont mis en place plusieurs aides
financières ils peuvent bénéficier à la
fois du crédit d'impôt pour la
transition énergétique donc qui résulte
de la nouvelle loi pour la transition
énergétique depuis le 1emier septembre
2014 ils peuvent bénéficier en fonction
des revenus de la prime rénovation
énergétique de 1350 € du programme
habité mieux qui est porté par l'ANA
l'Agence Nationale pour l'Amélioration
de l'Habitat et puis il y a aussi
l'coprè qui est un prêt à tau zéro des
aides qui existent depuis au moins
janvier 2014 le crédit d'impôt passé de
taux de 15 à 20 % à un taux unique à 30
% quels que soient les travaux fenêtres
chaudières ou isolation le pré à taux
zéro permet de bénéficier d'un montant
maximal de 30000 € et sans conditions de
ressources quelques images avant de se
quitter trois plus précisément trois
photos parmi lesquelles il faudra
choisir à Versailles en gare Rive Gauche
les usagers peuvent voter depuis ce
matin et jusqu'au 14 novembre pour
celles qu'il souhaiteraient voir
recouvrir les murs de l'édifice jardin
et statue galerie des glaces ou galerie
des Batailles l'installation en
trompeleuil aura ensuite lieu fin
décembre c'est à vous de voter pour la
décoration donc de la gare Versailles
Rive Gauche directement sur le stand
présent sur place pendant les deux
prochains jours le journal revient
demain toujours à 18h pour l'édition en
direct pour revoir nos reportage et nos
précédentes éditions rendez-vous sur le
site internet de la chaîne ce mercredi
soir sur TVfil nouveau numéro de kiosque
hebdomadaire dédié à la culture très
bonne
soirée